today on the matt walsh show the woke
mob cancels a contestant on the bachelor
and then cancels the host of the
bachelor for
defending the contestant so what does
this teach us about how cancel culture
works also five headlines including
trump getting his record second
impeachment acquittal uh plus biden
making a move on gun control
and cardi b advocating for chivalry
and in our daily cancellation i'm afraid
we have to talk about uh cosmo
and their article fetishizing
cannibalism
yes really all that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
now a quick word from legacy box most
important thing we have
you know in our homes are those the
memories the keepsakes the things that
uh that
remind us of maybe of our own childhood
or remind us of our kids and the times
we've had
uh that's why you don't want anything to
happen and you lose
all of that and so you shouldn't wait to
digitize priceless memories today
legacy box is an ingenious mailing
service to have all those irreplaceable
moments that are trapped on video tapes
camcorder tapes film reels
uh whatever it is pictures converted to
dvd or digital
home movies can transport us back to
unforgettable times
when was the last time you watched yours
probably been a long time one song one
photo one sniff of
nostalgia can take us back to you know
summer vacations
all the way back to childhood all of
that but what happens if you lose that
what if happened something something
happens they get damaged
isn't ensuring that your family's legacy
is digitally preserved so that it can be
passed down
just as important as creating those
memories in the first place i would say
so
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past the process
uh is uh is very easy from start to
finish all you got to do
is pack up whatever you want stored you
send it to them their team digitizes
everything and they send it back to you
and you enjoy it it's that easy
over 850 000 families have trusted them
to digitally preserve their past i am
one of those families
we couldn't be happier with the service
get started preserving your past today
go to legacybox.com
walsh to get an incredible 40 off your
first order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer
and then you can send in whenever you're
ready go to legacy box dot com slash
walsh and
save 40 off while supplies last so if
you
like me have never watched the bachelor
and are still a little bit confused
about what the bachelor
even is and are sure only that whatever
it is it's certainly entertainment for
people
with the iq of uh maybe a squid or
something
if this describes you then you have
missed the probably the latest
controversy surrounding the show
i bring it to your attention now as it
was brought to my attention only because
it's so
it's so perfectly emblematic of where we
are
as a culture so now try to try to follow
this story because it gets a little
gets a little twisty uh rachel kurt
connell or maybe it's kirk cannell
not sure is we'll go with kurt cannell
because it sounds fancier rachel kirk
cannell is a contestant
on the latest season of the bachelor
vying for the heart of one
matt james the contestants are all
trying to
actually marry him i think that's how it
works anyway matt james is a black man
and that shouldn't be relevant that
shouldn't matter but of course race is
always made relevant by the left these
days
it came out recently that rachel has a
history of racist
behavior and by racist behavior we mean
principally that she attended a frat
party
in 2018 with an antebellum south
theme and pictures from this gathering
uh
resurfaced as they say and she could be
seen
wearing a white hood and um with a with
a pointy top and lighting a cross on
fire so
no sorry actually never mind that's not
what the picture shows at all
no in the pictures she's wearing a pink
frilly dress
and and taking a selfie with her friends
that's it
antebellum as it turns out is not latin
for
racist or clan member it actually means
literally
before the war anti-bellum
so the antebellum south is the south
before the civil war yes the south
before the civil war
had slavery that's true um so did a huge
portion
of the rest of the globe at that time so
when when college kids go to an
antebellum party
they're not going there to celebrate
slavery that's not the idea they're
going there to wear fun
outfits and most crucially to drink
copious amounts of alcohol that's of
course always the real
uh the real goal of any college party so
and this is clear to any reasonable
person
right but we're running a shortage of
those kinds of people today so the
controversy raged internet sleuths
started digging up other suspicious
online activity from
this uh this girl edgy posts and and
photos the girls like the girl liked and
they dug up rumors from her time in
grade school
uh and the hunt was on they were on the
trail of another racist
or at least someone that they could
pretend was racist it's the same story
we've played out
we've seen play out a million times
before and as part of that story
we know that the apology always comes
next right
rachel kurt cannell issued a groveling
begging apology actually calling herself
a racist
multiple times in in the apology and
pleading for forgiveness for the harm
and damage
that she'd caused by wearing a frilly
dress and taking a picture
of course no forgiveness was given it
never is and that's when things take a
turn
for the even more insane chris harrison
is apparently the host of the bachelor
or was the host
he's he's now stepped down um after his
own racism controversy stemming from the
racism controversy
surrounding rachel if you think that
that simply being the host
of the bachelor was the most
embarrassing thing that chris harrison
would ever do
get a load of this because it gets a lot
worse he appeared on an interview show
on extra tv with a woman named rachel
lindsay
during that interview um this was early
last week
he was asked about the rachel kirk
canal stuff and he rambled for a little
bit but his point was simply that
we should uh we should have some grace
for her and we shouldn't ruin her life
over this
and he tried very very hard to make a
reasonable point
without ever taking a firm position he
tried very hard in fact
he uses the phrase i don't know about 50
different times
during this short part of the interview
and his point seems to be
we should have grace for this girl but
also
i don't know who knows please don't be
mad at me
let's listen to a clip of that what are
your thoughts about
rachel curcanell and the allegations
attached to her a couple of things first
and foremost i don't know
i haven't talked to rachel about it and
and this is again
where we all need to have a little grace
a little understanding a little
compassion because i've seen some stuff
online again this judge jury executioner
thing
where people are just tearing this
girl's life apart and diving into
like her parents and her parents voting
record and what it's it's
unbelievably alarming to watch this
i haven't heard rachel speak on this yet
and until i actually hear this woman
have a chance to speak
who am i to say any of this my guess
these girls got dressed up and went to a
party and had a great time they were 18
years old
now does that make it okay i don't know
rachel you tell me
again i am not the woke police there's
plenty of people plenty of people who
will do that for us in this world right
now
i don't know like do you do you go tear
all those places down
and and tear up the dirt and and dig
deep enough that it erases it i don't
know
um you know when you see san francisco
erasing lincoln
and erasing washington and erasing
people because of what they stood for
180 years ago and again
they may be right at the end of the day
i don't know i i'm just going to give
her the grace
and the time to actually come out and
speak and then hopefully i'll even have
a chance to debate her and i know you
will for sure she'll go on
extra or go on your podcast and
hopefully you'll have a great talk with
her
i don't know who knows i don't know i
don't know don't be mad
don't hate me gee guys i just think
maybe sorta we shouldn't
ruin this girl's life because she went
to a party in 2018 i don't know
maybe maybe don't be mad at me
well guess what they were mad at him uh
because of that what you just heard
there
he was accused of racism too and now
he's stepped down
after issuing his own groveling apology
where he also
uh confesses to causing damage to people
even though he caused no damage to
anyone and admits his that his actions
were racist even though they weren't
in the lead-up to him stepping down the
host of that interview rachel lindsay
complained um
that uh that he used his privilege
during the interview
and all the bachelor contestants came
out against him
and his own girlfriend his girlfriend
told the media
that he was defending racism and it's
unacceptable
much of this after his apology and they
still all
lined up to throw him under the bus
because the apology is never enough
and this this is why i bring this story
up and i think it's worth reflecting on
we are way past the point of saying
simply that people these days are
unforgiving
or that they fail to forgive or or they
fail to show grace
we are way past that we're at we're at a
point now where forgiveness
is ruled out categorically
to even advocate for it is
a sin just as bad as whatever sin you're
saying should be forgiven
even if the original sin was no sin at
all which most of the time
it isn't see what what this is really
about and has always been about
is cultural dominance the woke police as
chris harrison called them in that
interview back when he was pretending to
have some semblance of a spine
the woke police are looking for any
opportunity to impose their will and
that's really what this is about
to punish those who deviate uh from the
path
that the the woke mob has prescribed for
all of our lives
and that explains the seemingly sort of
weird fact that oftentimes
the people who defend the cancelled
person
will get cancelled even harder than the
original cancel e
it's because the defender is making a
more direct and explicit attack on the
woke mob's tactics
and therefore its authority even if that
attack is still extremely
circumspect and peppered with all kinds
of qualifiers and clauses and so on
as it was with chris harrison doesn't
matter anyone who dares to speak up and
say
no you know i don't think you guys
should be doing
it this way anyone who does that will
get the harshest treatment of all
harrison's girlfriend knew that that's
why she threw him right on the bus
all the contestants on the show
everybody gets the message
right and that's how this is supposed to
work
i said last week that the woke mob uh
takes
your scalp once it cancels you they take
the scalp and they nail it to their wall
as a trophy well
that was actually wrong that's actually
not exactly correct
i think it's truer to say that they take
off your head
and they put it on a pike and leave it
on the outskirts of town
as a warning to any other challengers
that's really what what it is it's
ruthless it's bloodthirsty
and it's extremely effective and to
stand up to them
to really stand up against them to
really defy them
will take a lot more courage and
backbone than the host of the bachelor
apparently possesses no big surprise
there
i suppose now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
before we go any further quick word from
our very good friends over at prageru
you know you think about the education
system
all the problems that are there we've
spent many shows talking about it uh
critical race theory choosing your own
gender
gender theory nonsense climate change
doom and gloom the attack on
american history all of that and the
left-wing nonsense
is now taught from kindergarten through
grad school they they
they don't wait until high school now
it's like they start all the way in
kindergarten it's turning kids into
left-wing activists
by indoctrinating them before they're
you know
before they have the the psychological
capability to
um to you know sort through fiction
and uh and and fable that they're taught
in schools millions of kids
have have to attend these schools and
this is what they're subjected to and
this is why we need to fight back
my friends at prager you know exactly
what we're up against and they're doing
something about it right now
several of us here at the daily wire are
featured in prageru videos
prageru knows how to educate millions of
young people like no other non-profit
now prageru is taking on k-12 education
with prageru resources for educators and
parents known as prep
if you are a parent or a teacher uh you
need to join this group
today there's no time to waste this is
the most powerful community of
conservative parents and educators in
america uh you can join prep at
prageru.com forward slash
prep that's p-r-e-p i can't recommend
this highly enough even you know
again teacher or a parent you need to be
prepared you need to have the resources
with prep you'll save
you'll save our children from this
leftist brainwashing best of all you'll
join thousands of members already
working together to make sure
education reflects our values as it
should
we need you on our side this is this is
what our strength is going to be our
strength is in numbers we have the
numbers what we need now though is to is
to come together as a community
that's what prep is all about join prep
today by going right now to prageru.com
forward slash prep so a big ice storm
here in nashville that's why none of us
are in the studio right now
uh because of because of the the big ice
storm and when i say big ice storm
i mean we got some freezing rain
and some sleet and there's a little bit
of snow on the ground
but this and this is my first winter in
nashville and i come from up north now
when i say up north i mean like the
mid-atlantic region i'm talking i'm
talking about i'm not talking alaska
right um but even by that by
even comparing it to that by those
standards this is really nothing
you know i i can remember many a time
many of the time many of winter
in maryland you wake up in the morning
there's some freezing rain
there's some sleet overnight and you say
oh okay and you just go about your day
don't you just go you drive you can do
whatever you want to do
um my first winter in uh
in nashville and i'm discovering that it
it doesn't quite work that way around
here you get a little bit of freezing
rain and it
shuts everything down everything is shut
down
and it's not just that um it's not just
that the city fails to
treat the roads no salt no pre-treatment
in fact yesterday morning when it just
first started it was a little bit of
freezing rain
and because like i said i'm used to i'm
used to it a certain way so i woke up
and i had to run to the store
and i thought well whatever what am i
going to stay home because of some
freezing rain ridiculous
and so i gotta go out on the road and
it's like the apocalypse there are
there are already cars strewn all over
the highway people hitting guard rails
hitting each other
um skidding sliding
because i had done no pre-treatment on
the roads at all no salt nothing
and on top of that people are speeding
through
like like it's warm and sunny out
and i always you see those those kinds
of signs on the highway sometimes
signs that say like bridge is slippery
when wet and that sort of thing
and i always see those signs and think
well who actually needs that sign
doesn't everyone understand water makes
the road slippery ice
ice is slippery water slippery and now
i'm seeing that no i guess this is
there are some people who need the signs
because people flying down the road with
ice on
the road and it makes it totally
hazardous so now after
a day of that um it's total shutdown
here
and uh we might be i don't know it might
be six months before
before we can uh go out on the road
again we'll see
all right number one donald trump as you
i'm sure heard acquitted in the senate
trial 57 votes to convict 43 to acquit
um and uh so that's his makes makes his
record
second acquittal and i i think the thing
i i didn't pay a lot of attention i paid
about as much attention to this
impeachment trial as i did to the last
one
and uh i didn't pay any attention to
that one so i paid very little attention
but i will say
my analysis of the thing that i didn't
really watch is that what sealed the
deal
probably for getting him the acquittal
was
um when trump's lawyers brought up all
the times
that the democrats had blatantly
condoned
and encouraged rioting and that really
does matter
yeah it's this is not what about ism it
does matter
when when when the people who are
putting you on
trial for a certain thing that you
allegedly did
actually did the thing that they're
accusing you of doing
and we've got hours of video of them
doing it yeah that matters
of course that's going to be brought up
um they
they just don't have the the
the grounds to make this kind of charge
against anyone
when they spent months and months and
months
in a much more explicit fashion
encouraging and condoning rioting the
only thing that made
it the only thing that stopped it from
being completely explicit
is that they renamed rioting unrest
and then they took that word unrest and
went ahead and
absolutely um defended it and condoned
it and encouraged it
and said we need more of it
representative
jamie raskin kind of looking for the
bright side says that well
at least we got trump to admit that he's
a former president
listen it is what it is uh mitch
mcconnell clearly feels
that uh donald trump remains a huge
problem for the republican party even if
he has been
disgraced in the eyes of the country and
that
is not my jurisdiction and i really
don't have anything to say about that i
think
you know that they will uh they have to
deal with the political dynamics
uh within their within their own party
so
um we did get um
we did get donald trump at least to
admit that he's a former president
now so that's good news uh he's not
asserting that somehow he's still
president
um and they're recognizing at least in a
de facto sense
the legitimacy of this presidential
election which of course
president biden won by more than seven
million votes and by a margin
um of 306 to 232
306 to 232 in the electoral college
well that's one thing at least grasping
at straws you you take what you can get
i suppose
meanwhile eric swalwell um in reaction
to the decision
found a way to be a bigger tool than
usual he's always
he's always a tool we know but he always
finds a way it's kind of impressive he
finds a way to up the ante
and he really did he really did this
time listen
the choice was well do we chase those
people
not knowing what they're going to say to
the courts for
years or do we go forward with a
powerful thundering case that we have
and also knowing that mitch mcconnell
was already telling us that
he believed the challenge was a
jurisdictional one so we could have
called god herself
and the republicans weren't going to be
willing to convict so we're proud of the
case we put forward
god herself god herself
well eric swalwell's just deciding for
god
what his new pronouns are going to be i
guess we
no more respecting the pronouns he's
just decided it's not even like swalwell
is going with some sort of
gender-neutral thing because he's saying
well we don't really know what what
gender god is or god is beyond gender
um that's not even what he's doing he's
just assigning dif he's still he's still
going with the gender but he's just
assigning a different one to god
saying this is going to be god's gender
now because because i said so
and of course if you're a democrat you
don't really believe in god anyway no
matter what you
say then then it doesn't doesn't make a
difference as far as you're concerned
okay number two from cnn um ravi
zacharias
uh the prominent head of a global
christian organization who died in may
and
engaged in sexual misconduct that
included sexting
unwanted touching spiritual abuse and
rape according to a statement from the
minute from the ministry he founded
summarizing the results of investigative
reports so this is from his
own ministry saying this um allegations
came from four
female massage therapists who said
zacharias would either touch his
genitals or ask them to
ask them to touch his genitals
additionally five massage therapists
claimed quote
he touched or rubbed them
inappropriately and one reported quote
many encounters over a period of years
that she described as rape according to
a 12-page report
from the law firm miller and martin
which was hired by the ministry
the law firm said it employed a private
investigation
firm that included former federal law
enforcement officers
more than 50 people were interviewed
including more than a dozen massage
therapists
according to the report several women
accused zacharias of using ministry
funds to give them financial support
eliciting personal information about
their lives and employing religious
language during encounters according to
the report
uh and then it goes on to all the all of
the
um all the gross and disturbing details
you can
look it up if you want i now maybe
depending on you know
depending on how closely you follow
christian apologetics
uh you you know maybe you've heard of
ravi zacharias maybe you haven't but
he was a very prominent christian
apologist
um and so this is it's sort of
exhausting to see this kind of thing
from christian leaders i i think we're
exhausted by it aren't we
every time you see it now your first
reaction is another one
jeez um
and in this case now i ca i wasn't the
you know i wasn't like a follower of
ravi zacharias
um but just i like to watch
debates christian debates and and talks
and
lectures and those sorts of things on
youtube and so i've come across a lot of
ravi zacharias i've watched some of it
uh i always thought he was pretty good
in that role and so even with that
little bit of exposure to him i saw this
and my first reaction was to be
sort of shocked not him too him
but of course then you realize there's
no there's no cause
for being surprised or shocked
because in reality you think about how
many people in your life do you really
know right how many how many people in
your life do you really
actually know how many people in the
world i should say do you really
actually know it's like almost almost
none of the people in the world
do you know the actual people you know
people closest to you
the people that are absolutely closest
to you in your own life hopefully your
spouse your kids you know
um very close friends those are the ones
you know and
everybody else you really don't you see
someone
on youtube you you know you you listen
to them you
whatever it is um public figure
even if you've been following them for
years you still don't really know
anything about them all you see is what
they present on camera
and that doesn't tell you much at all so
there's no cause
actually for being surprised
but even so it's extremely disappointing
and disheartening to see this from yet
another
another one of these people number three
democrat president joe biden called on
congress
to clamp down on americans
constitutionally protected second
amendment rights on sunday
this is from daily wire demanding gun
bans and new laws that will allow people
to sue gun manufacturers
biden wrote to congress i am calling on
congress to enact common sense gun law
reforms including requiring background
checks on all gun sales
banning assault weapons and high
capacity magazines and eliminating
immunity for gun manufacturers who
knowingly put weapons of war on our
streets
uh a more common sense gun reform that
he's calling for
and you know i i
i have to say of course i'm concerned
about this because we've got democrat
control of the government
and we know that they're going to make a
play against gun rights and gun rights
of course
one of the most crucial rights that we
have so i'm concerned about it from from
that
angle but looked at another way i'm
actually not all that concerned about it
because and maybe i'm being naive and
and uh
and hopelessly optimistic i don't know
sometimes i'm accused of that not very
often though
but i'm not i'm not terribly concerned
about it because because
this is like the one area gun rights
where the rights conservatives
have actually stood their ground and
put the line in sand and said you're not
going to cross here
and the left has been trying and we all
think about all through the obama years
eight years through the obama years
how hard they tried every time there was
a school shooting or anything that they
could exploit
and they made very little progress in
that direction
they're there they have gotten a few
things through there have been a few
assaults on gun rights that were more
effective than
all the others but for the most part
they have not this has been the
this has been maybe the one area where
the left has consistently
failed and so i'm going to say i think
they'll fail again
because that line in the sand
this is this is the the one issue
where conservatives have simply said i'm
not gonna budge
we're not gonna compromise on this we're
not gonna let you have it
nope and so no matter really it's no
matter
what gun control
uh policy is proposed doesn't matter
what it is
most conservatives will say i don't care
i'm not even gonna listen because i'm
not gonna
we're not gonna go along with it we're
not gonna let you take any of this
and that's great this is not a complaint
on my my part at all that's fantastic i
only wish we could do that with
i don't know everything else i wish we
could have that approach in that
attitude with every other issue
especially issues that are more
fundamental and more important than gun
rights
like for example life protecting the
the right to life or to protecting the
dignity of life
um i i wish we could take that same
approach
on something like abortion we're not
gonna budge
we're not gonna let you have this of
course
it's way too late now for us to say
you're not gonna have this they've
already taken it
but we could still be that aggressive
and that firm
on life on protecting the family on
protecting children
so i think we should look at what's
happened with gun rights
um and gun rights advocates and and what
they're doing and we should emulate that
with every other issue stand firm
don't give an inch we're not gonna
compromise we're not gonna give you
anything
uh number four there was a viral clip
last week of tom brady celebrating his
super bowl win
and at one point he tosses the lombardi
trophy from his boat to another boat
where other players he actually tosses
the the whole trophy
um across the water and to another boat
and the people there catch
the uh the trophy it's a great throw
great catch
very exciting but for whatever reason
the media tracked down the daughter
of the guy who designed the lombardi
trophy originally
and she was not pleased and it takes a
lot of work
a lot of hard work a lot of hours go
into it
it just really upset me that this trophy
was
disgraced and disrespected by being
thrown as if it was a real football
i didn't sleep for the past two nights
because of this i was that upset
because i i know the passion that goes
into this trophy
and how my dad and all his fellow
silversmiths are so
proud to make this i personally would
like
an apology not just to me
and my family and the other silversmiths
um but to the to the fans
two nights she was up for two nights two
nights she was up thinking about this
pretty amazing but why are we why would
you even
think to go talk to this woman
who cares what she thinks about or her
dad designed the original lombardi
trophy so what
okay now we need her opinion about tom
brady throwing a libar to joby i i don't
really see the connection
but you know that's what the media does
you gotta find a controversy
anywhere you can if they have if the
modern american media has any talent at
all that's it just to
take any banal occurrence and find a way
to make it controversial
number five finally cardi b sparked her
own controversy last week with this
tweet she said
yes men do deserve to get a gift as well
for valentine's day but the gift has to
be
less expensive than the girl's gift so
if he buys you flowers you buy him grass
right now we're going to leave aside all
the misspellings and she used
t-h-e-n instead of t-h-a and uh so we'll
put all that aside but
you know here's the here's the thing
with this and i and i'm i'm not the
first one to point this out at all so
i'm going to echo
the sentiments of of many others when i
say this but
um no cardi b so you don't get to do
this you
you don't get to do this you see you
can't go with the empowered independent
feminist woman schtick
in one second and then in the next
second do this
where you expect the man to pay more or
you know to to do more for valentine's
day than you do
you really you really do have to choose
it's going to be one of the other
if you you know if if women are exactly
equal to men and by that i mean
the same as just they're
interchangeable which is what the left
believes
men and women are interchangeable
there's no real difference between them
um and if if it's all about being
empowered and independent
and you don't need no man and you
certainly don't need a man to protect
and provide
for you then you know it's you're gonna
you're gonna pay the same
you're gonna pay the same for gifts
you're gonna pay the same when you go
out to eat
uh that's the way it's gonna go you
can't
you can't try to you know cherry-pick
here and let's let's
let's take the the best parts of
left-wing feminism we'll take that for
ourselves but then also
the best parts of chivalry we're going
to take that too nope
doesn't work one or the other one
now it happens to be my my personal
opinion
that yeah well valentine's day is a
silly
silly holiday anyway fake holiday anyway
but um
certainly uh my opinion is
the woman should get the man doesn't
really you don't need a gift at all for
for valentine's day if you're a man
it's sort of embarrassing to get a gift
you should you certainly shouldn't
expect
or or want a gift uh but i can have that
perspective because i don't subscribe to
left-wing feminism so there's no
conflict
there's no contradiction there is for
you so you need to choose
all right let's go to comments we're
going to read the youtube comments now
of course the most uh
the newest the latest and greatest
segment on the show some of the comments
on the
on the youtube show last week on friday
this is from uh
colella says who needs disney plus
anyway when matt wall show is available
for free
and then some sort of emoji but then you
included that emoji so i don't know what
that is
this is one of my problems with emojis
one of the reasons i hate emojis is i
i can never tell exactly what they're
supposed to mean
um so this is the match wall show is
available for free and then
it's an emoji of someone sort of
smirking and looking to the side
is that your is that is that to
communicate sarcasm see i don't know you
could have just attacked me for all i
know and i'm not sure
philip says hey matt looking for advice
on flannel shirts i have several but i'm
not sure if any are giving off that
i'm here to party vibe and by party i
mean conservative catholics settle down
and have kids and prefer to be home by
nine
well you can't go wrong with flannels as
you can tell
a flat that's the whole attraction with
flannels is if you if you have if you're
a man you have
no sense of style whatsoever throw on a
flannel throw on the jeans and you're
good to go joseph says morgan wallen
inspired me to learn how to play guitar
and this is just incredible his music is
wonderful and i support him 100
um yeah i've got a lot of comments like
that we've talked about the morgan
wilderness
situation and um i never really
i'll be honest i didn't know who he was
because i don't really follow country
music i didn't even know who he was
until all this happened but
a lot of comments from people saying big
fans of his music big supporters of his
that's the other thing to keep in mind
when you're getting canceled
that probably
especially if they're if they're if
you're being canceled over some ticky
tack thing
the people who are attacking you and
coming after you
they they were never supporters to begin
with
so maybe it feels like public opinion
has
changed or there's people are turning
against you
and maybe in the case of chris harrison
that's really true his own girlfriend
came out against him
but it might it might sort of depend on
what circles you run in but
for someone like morgan wallen who's
apologized multiple times now
his actual fans i really doubt that any
of them
uh turned against him and started
calling him a racist because of this
so these were all people who probably
like me had never even heard of him
before
and now they're saying oh that morgan
wallin is a real racist who cares what
they think
jimmy jim jim says hey matt i've heard
you say you won't get the coronavirus
vaccine why is that how do you feel
about vaccines in general and why do you
get the flu vaccine
i'd love to hear your thoughts on this i
think a lot of us would
the reason why i'm not going to get the
chronic virus vaccine is simply because
i don't i don't personally feel like i
need it
i'm not in a high risk category i think
i may have already had the coronavirus
back in february
of last year um and whether i did or
didn't
i'm i'm not in a high-risk category
there's a very low chance
that i would have any serious any very
serious reaction to the chronovirus to
begin with and so i don't
i simply don't feel like for me it's
something that i need but that that's a
choice that i can make
i should be able to make and everyone
can make their own choices and that's my
opinion on vaccines in general whether
it's the chronovirus vaccine the flu
vaccine or the vaccine for anything else
you make the decision for yourself if
you're a parent you make the decision
for your child
and people should make their own
decisions it depends on what you
think your your risk category is uh what
you're comfortable doing
because you are injecting something into
your body or having something injected
into your kid's body
and no i don't think you should do it if
you're not comfortable with it um
if you are then go ahead so that's it
that's my that's my whole perspective on
vaccines if you want to take it due if
you don't
don't do what you feel like is right for
you i i really don't have an opinion
about if
someone else should get a vaccine that's
up to them to decide
uh and finally malachi says matt you
should really stop banning people from
the show you won't have any listeners
left
well malachi you know what's going to
happen now because of that comment
you are banned quick word now from our
friends at rock auto you know if you
have
car problems if you have car trouble
there are a couple ways you can go about
solving that problem you can go get in
your car drive to an auto parts store
look around for what you need pay more
than you need to
there's not a great selection maybe they
don't have what you need they got to
order it anyway
you're dealing with all these questions
from the the person there at the store
you can do that or you could just grab
your phone out of your pocket or go to
your laptop on your desk
and go to rockauto.com and find
everything you could possibly need
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what they think the market will bear
like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts that's the really simple
question you have to ask yourself i
don't think you could come up with a
good reason to do that
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all the prices at rockauto.com
are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals or do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts again there's no reason at
all to do that
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need at
rockauto.com
go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck and remember to write walsh in
there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you as i'm
sure you uh
know actress gina carano has been making
her way through the news cycle recently
she was the star of the hit disney plus
show the
mandalorian she was dropped from the
series and by her talent agency for
criticizing
the woke hollywood mob so they sort of
proved her point then
by by canceling her at one point in time
this would have been another
conservative voice silenced out of the
entertainment world but that's no longer
the case doesn't work that way now
because the daily wire
rejects cantal culture and everything it
stands for and we're prepared to fight
back so that's why
we just announced a new movie deal with
gina that's correct she'll be developing
producing and starring in an upcoming
film that will be released exclusively
to daily wire members this is pretty
exciting you know we we we've all said
it conservatives need to do more than
complain and critique
we need to step we need to stop running
away from the culture we need to be
creators and influencers that challenge
the leftist narrative in hollywood
and we do that by creating good art that
stands on its own
in the world of entertainment and that's
what we're going to do we bring in gina
disney plus has 8 billion
uh dollars to spend per year we have you
they've got 8 billion bucks we've got
you so join us today in the fight to
take back
our culture go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code gina that's
g-i-n-a
to get 25 off your membership today make
sure to do that
this is the way let's get to our daily
cancellation
today we're going to cancel cosmo again
cosmetic cosmopolitan magazine is
getting canceled this will make i
believe
their fourth or fifth or sixth i don't
know cancellation so far they're behind
only
uh alexandria casa cortez and my own
family members for total number of
cancellations
this one is richly richly deserved
the most deserved of all in fact and i
should warn you ahead of time if you're
listening to this show
with little kids anywhere with an ear
shot maybe hit that pause button and
circle back
as jen pasaki would say because this is
this is graphic and disturbing stuff
i'll tell you ahead of time yet there's
an important takeaway so
um i i think it may be worth wading into
this swamp for the takeaway maybe worth
we'll see
for some background army hammer is an
actor who
along with having maybe the greatest
name of all time also has starred
in a number of films i couldn't tell you
what any of those films are
but trust me he started them whatever
they are
well it's come out though nobody was
asking that army hammer
allegedly has a cannibalism fetish
one of his ex-girlfriends reported quote
he said to me he wants to break my rib
and barbecue and eat it
not the kind of thing you say on a first
date or really any date
yeah i'm not sure in the cannibalism
community
what the standard etiquette really is
like when do you tell your girlfriend or
boyfriend that you want to consume them
maybe you bring it up while eating could
provide the nice conversation transition
you know like hey speaking of dinner
i wanted to ask you something anyway i
joke because that's how i deal with
insanely disturbing things cosmo had a
different method though their
way of dealing with it was to throw up
in their arms and embrace it totally
which brings us to this article with the
headline
yes there's a safe way to have a
cannibalism fetish
the army hammer story's not it
now you would of course assume that this
is a guest
op-ed written by hannibal lecter or
something but no it's from
maria del russo based on a conversation
with someone named
jet setting jasmine the latter is quote
a fetish educator
how does one get a job as a fetish
educator
what does one do in this job what does
the nine to five look like
how long will it be until universities
are actually offering degrees
in fetish education are they already
offering degrees in that
in that field these are all questions
that go unanswered here's what the
article does say
um reading now quote
here's what i've been seeing people get
wrong in the conversation about army
hammer and the abuse allegations against
him
his alleged cannibalism fetish itself is
in the problem
beg to differ ma'am i really do the
problem is if the allegations are true
whether he used his power to groom these
women into participating in a lifestyle
they had truly not consented to
a cannibalism fetish is characterized by
a person who fantasizes about consuming
someone or being consumed
the key word is fantasy the fetish never
goes so far as actually eating or
killing someone of course
that'd be illegal just having the
conversation around eating someone and
being sexually stimulated by that
it's considered a cannibalism fetish
just having the conversation
when you bring up cannibalism the other
person should be disturbed it's like hey
hey
i'm i'm just having a conversation about
eating you that's it
it's it's only a conversation sit back
down okay
everything will be fine now okay so if
you got that
it's illegal right actually killing and
eating someone is illegal
and that's why you shouldn't do it you
shouldn't kill or eat someone because
it's illegal
not because it's completely evil sick
twisted depraved disgusting
the most barbaric act a person can
possibly commit
no because it's illegal that's it the
article continues
once the allegations against hammer blew
up the internet all the media attention
zeroed in on the word cannibalism
well yeah it that that tends to stick
out
that's uh one of those things we we tend
to notice so you throw cannibalism into
a story people are gonna
people are gonna focus on it that's the
way it goes she says
we were totally titillated by the taboo
but i'd like to offer a different
framework one where we understand
hammer's alleged behavior is troubled
but not necessarily because of the c
word well because of the potential
absence of another c word
consent any form of grooming into a
lifestyle without consent is a violation
consent is the difference between
bdsm and non-bdsm uh encounters
we cannot actually consider and
encounter true bdsm if there isn't
consent involved
the minute that a hookup does not have
clear consent it has already fallen out
of bdsm and into an
inappropriate uh interaction okay you
see consent
that's all that matters here and we'll
get back to that in a minute but let me
read one more part
all right what does a consensual form
of cannibalism look like well here it is
a consensual form of bdsm play featuring
a cannibalism fetish would go like this
somebody might say i know i can't
actually eat your hand off
but i can suck your fingers until you
tell me to stop to stop or nibble on you
blood play is another fetish called
hematolagnia
and that can present as someone being
turned on by any form of blood during
sex okay
i told you it's gonna get disturbing
there it is
quick tip here if you ever find yourself
uttering the sentence
i know i can't actually eat your hand
off but
stop right there you you you have gone
to a dark place because
nothing can good can come after that
butt that is one sentence that should
not require
a butt okay so what's the point here
what's the takeaway besides that
cosmo is a degenerate publication that
pushes filth and garbage
well that's one takeaway the other
takeaway is that this is the absolute
depths of insanity of wicked wickedness
of evil of perversion
that we sink to as a culture when
consent
is the only sexual ethic we recognize
right
if the only moral rule governing your
sexual exploits is simply that the other
person
has to verbally agree to be a part of it
then it's uh it's pretty much guaranteed
that you'll end up
in dark dark places hopefully not all
the way in a prison cell with a bite
mask on your face giving a detective
tips on how to catch a serial killer
but still you know dark places but this
has been the direction
we've gone as a culture for a long time
we've stripped away the entire moral
framework from the sexual act
leaving only consent and then we're
shocked to find ourselves surrounded by
freaks and weirdos
we're also shocked to find that people
are constantly left feeling abused and
used in their sexual relationships
even when there was no actual abuse by
legal standards so putting cannibalism
to the side
for a moment why do you think there are
so many cases of women having consensual
encounters with men
and then later saying it was
non-consensual
that it was rape i mean some of it is is
pure cruelty manipulation deceit
false accusations and all that but i
think there's something else happening
too i think in many cases
people have consensual encounters but
wake up in the next morning
feeling used and cheap and degraded
and then because consent is the only
ethical language we have for sex
they figure that it must mean that
consent was not real consent
because that's the that is the only
moral standard the only moral rule
and so if you wake up feeling bad the
next day you figure well that that rule
must have been violated even if it
wasn't
it must have been the truth is this
consent is simple right if you agree to
do something
whatever it is you consent it unless
that agreement was
forced or coerced but then that's not
really agreement
so if there is actual agreement then
that's consent whatever it is period
but then why do people consent and later
still feel so
terrible so degraded well because
consensual sex
can still be terrible and degrading it's
legal
it's not rape but the sexual act in
modern culture has become an occasion
for both partners or however many
partners to
consensually use each other to treat
each other like objects
and sex becomes glorified masturbation
and this is a bad thing
it's consensual but it's bad see it's
possible for sex
to be consensual and bad at the same
time
but we've decided that consent is the
only rule the only standard
we don't have the language to um
communicate on this anymore we don't we
don't even have the language to explain
why a cannibalism fetish is bad even
though almost all of us innately know
that it is
but in modern culture today i think most
people will read that article and be
horrified even people on the left
will read that article and be horrified
by it but
if they've bought into this framework
they're going to find that okay
they're going to say to themselves yeah
this seems disgusting and wrong to me
but
i can't figure out why it is i couldn't
possibly explain why it is
because yeah if they consent then i
guess that's it it's fine
two consenting adults right that's all
that matters
let me suggest some other language that
we could use in relation to sex
um love devotion commitment
here's a big one dignity we don't like
these words we're scared of them
but this is the proper framework for the
sexual act
the sexual act should be loving devoted
committed
and it should be respecting of our own
and the other's dignity
and here's the great thing if you have
these bases covered
right then consent comes with it
you don't need to talk about consent
it's a really basic part of the love
dignity devotion package you don't need
to say
well sex should be loving devoted uh
there should be dignity and there should
be consent
because that is already part of all of
those other things
obviously if you're having sex with
someone without with other consent then
it's not loving devoted or and it's not
respecting their dignity so
that that's already part of it
so make sure that you're only having sex
with a person that you love
and are devoted to and are committed to
i.e
married to and that you're preserving
their and your own dignity do that
and you won't wake up the next morning
feeling awful and cheap and used and
wondering if even though you gave
consent maybe you didn't really give
consent
also you won't have to worry about your
sexual partner you know
trying to cook you for dinner so that's
that's another positive that's another
plus bring bring
love devotion and dignity back into sex
a lot of our problems will be solved if
we do that
and cosmo will go out of business that's
maybe the best consequence of all
in the meantime though cosmo is
cancelled
and i have to say although i shouldn't
have to
all cannibals are also definitely
canceled
that'll do it for us today uh thanks for
watching thanks for listening stay safe
out there
in the winter apocalypse i'll talk to
you tomorrow gun speed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show trump gets acquitted by
the senate in his impeachment trial plus
the biden administration is obviously
just screwing with the science on kova
to please the teachers unions that's
today on the ben shapiro show tune in